This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. When was the last time you stayed awake at night, unable to sleep, replaying something in your head that happened that day? Did you notice how your thoughts coil back on themselves, how you went in circles as the night wore on? All of us, even those who have been spared the pain of insomnia, have heard that voice. If you've messed up a presentation at work or flubbed the tested school or been rejected in love,
这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔。你上一次彻夜难眠、脑海中不断重演当天发生的事情是什么时候？你有没有注意到你的思绪是如何纠缠在一起的，随着夜色渐深，你是如何陷入死循环的？我们所有人，即使是那些没有经历过失眠痛苦的人，也都听到过那个声音。如果你在工作中搞砸了一次演讲，或者在考试中失利，又或者在爱情中被拒绝，
you've heard those nagging, doubting thoughts, borrowing themselves deeper and deeper into the recesses of your brain. Oh, how can I say something so stupid? Why did I- How does a mess- I'm always so stupid? Why do I have to do this? I was a mess. I'm always so lazy. I really should have worked out. I do not believe you forgot to fill out that permission form. You forgot about parent's or your conferences.
你一定听到过那些唠叨、怀疑的念头，它们正不断钻进你大脑的深处。噢，我怎么能说出这么蠢的话？为什么我——这怎么搞的——我总是这么蠢？我为什么要这么做？我真是个废物。我总是这么懒。我真的应该去锻炼的。我真不敢相信你忘了填那张许可表。你忘了家长会或者你的会议。
What the hell? Thirds. My back hurts. My body is just falling apart. Why does this inner voice seem to love to torment us? Wouldn't life be better if we could just make it stop? When that negative inner voice takes hold, that is all we can hear because it is consuming our attention.
搞什么鬼？第三次了。我的背好痛。我的身体简直要垮了。为什么这个内心声音似乎很喜欢折磨我们？如果我们能让它停下来，生活会不会更好？当那个消极的内心声音占据主导时，我们只能听到它，因为它消耗了我们所有的注意力。
Today we kick off our long awaited annual series, U2.0. All through the month of August, we'll bring you stories that will help you see yourself and the people around you with fresh eyes. We'll also give you research-based ideas on how to approach life's challenges with wisdom. There's a fallacy that your first thoughts are your best thoughts and so you don't want to trust your gut, you want to test your gut. I don't think there's very much evidence at all that people are chokers or thrivers and I think anyone can learn to perform better at what makes them most
今天，我们开启了期待已久的年度系列节目“U2.0”。在整个八月，我们将为你带来一些故事，帮助你以全新的视角看待自己和周围的人。我们还将提供基于研究的建议，教你如何以智慧应对生活的挑战。有一种谬论认为，你的第一直觉就是最好的想法，所以你不应该相信直觉，而应该去检验直觉。我认为并没有太多证据表明人们要么是“关键时刻掉链子”的人，要么是“压力下表现更好”的人，我认为任何人都可以学会如何在最让自己
nervous when the pressure is on. The people who know us well are good observers of our behavior and often can deduce our feelings better than we can. We begin our series by examining that nagging voice inside your head. How it works and what you can do to make it work for you this week on Hidden Brain. You might be an expert, you might be a novice, you could be a veteran or just starting out in your career. You've almost certainly heard that voice inside your head questioning if you know enough questioning if you are enough. At the University of Michigan, psychologist Ethan Cross studies that voice, what it does, why it exists, and how we can learn to befriend it. Ethan Cross, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks for having me, Shankar. It's an absolute delight to Hidden Brain. Thanks for having me, Sean Cards. Absolutely delighted to be here.
紧张的时刻表现得更好。那些了解我们的人是很好的行为观察者，他们往往比我们自己更能推断出我们的感受。我们通过审视你脑海中那个唠叨的声音来开启这个系列。本周在《Hidden Brain》中，我们将探讨它是如何运作的，以及你可以做些什么来让它为你所用。你可能是一位专家，也可能是一位新手，你可能是一位老手，也可能刚刚开始你的职业生涯。你几乎肯定听到过脑海中那个声音在质疑你是否知道得足够多，质疑你是否足够优秀。在密歇根大学，心理学家伊森·克罗斯研究了那个声音，它做了什么，它为什么存在，以及我们如何学会与它成为朋友。伊森·克罗斯，欢迎来到《Hidden Brain》。谢谢你邀请我，尚卡尔。非常高兴能来到《Hidden Brain》。谢谢你邀请我，尚卡尔。非常高兴能来到这里。
Ethan, I want to start by talking about a couple of incidents in your own life, where you had to confront what you call the chatter of your own in our voice. When you started college at the University of Pennsylvania, you came in as a very strong student with stellar grades from high school. Can you tell me how you fared academically in your first few months at Penn? I think the best word that I could use to describe my experiences, it was a disaster academically.
伊森，我想先谈谈你生活中的几个事件，当时你不得不面对你所说的内心声音中的“杂音”。当你开始在宾夕法尼亚大学上大学时，你作为一名高中成绩优异的学生入学。你能告诉我你在宾大最初几个月的学业表现如何吗？我想我能用来描述我经历的最好的词是：学业上的灾难。
My first semester, I came in, I had graduated as valedictorian from my high school and thought I knew how to study. And it turned out I did not know how to study very well for college classes and ended up getting a sea of bad grades and I also felt like I didn't exactly fit in at Penn. I had come from a working-class neighborhood in Brooklyn and I was surrounded now by students from more privileged backgrounds that I had come from, and they
第一学期，我入学时是高中毕业典礼的致辞代表，以为自己知道如何学习。结果发现我并不太懂得如何应对大学课程，最终得到了一连串糟糕的成绩，而且我觉得自己并不完全适合宾大。我来自布鲁克林的一个工人阶级社区，现在周围都是背景比我优越得多的学生，他们
talked different. They dressed different. So all of those thoughts about whether I fit in, whether I belong, that became a distraction. And that weighed on me. That there was a mental burden that exerted, which was unpleasant and was something I had to figure out how to address. I want to fast forward a couple of decades to another moment in your life when the voice inside your head was deafening. You'd become a successful academic. You were married. You had a growing family and wonder, you were playing with your young daughter getting her ready for her nap. Can you
说话方式不同。他们的穿着也不同。所以，所有关于我是否合群、是否属于这里的想法，都成了干扰。这让我感到沉重。这是一种心理负担，令人不快，是我必须想办法解决的问题。我想快进几十年，谈谈你生命中另一个内心声音震耳欲聋的时刻。你已经成为了一名成功的学者。你结婚了。你有了不断壮大的家庭，有一天，你正在和年幼的女儿玩耍，准备哄她午睡。你能
paint me a detailed picture of what you were doing and what happened next season? This is a painful experience, even when I reflect back on it now. When my youngest daughter was less than one at the time or right around that age, we would have this ritual of sorts that we would engage in where before her nap, I'd read to her, I'd play a little bit, change her diaper, and then I would like launch her off of the changing table, swirl her up and down like a spaceship in the sky, and then flip her on her back and very quickly kind of put her down in the crib and she would love it, always smiles and she always expected
为我详细描述一下你当时在做什么，以及接下来发生了什么吗？即使现在回想起来，这也是一段痛苦的经历。当时我最小的女儿还不到一岁，或者就在那个年纪，我们有一种仪式，在午睡前，我会给她读书，玩一会儿，换尿布，然后我会把她从换尿布台上“发射”出去，像太空船一样在空中上下旋转，然后迅速把她翻过来，放进婴儿床里，她很喜欢这样，总是笑嘻嘻的，她总是期待着
it. So something we she always expected it. So something we did every single time. And this one episode, I started going through the procedure, she knew exactly what was coming, she was loving it. And the only problem is when I went to land her, so to speak in the crib, she started screaming. And when I say screaming, I mean, I'm talking about ear
它。所以这是我们每次都会做的事情。而这一次，我开始走流程，她很清楚接下来会发生什么，她很享受。唯一的问题是，当我把她放进婴儿床时，她开始尖叫。当我说是尖叫时，我是指那种震耳欲聋的
shattering screams were coming out of out of her mouth. And she started grabbing reaching for her arm. And so I immediately called my wife, told her what happened. She then started to come home from work. And I'm then just I'm sitting on the rocking chair with my daughter screaming, looking at me and I'm thinking, oh my God, what did I do? I started simulating in my mind the worst case scenarios. Have I permanently injured her or are we going to need surgery? Oh my God, what a surgery like when a kid is this young.
尖叫声从她嘴里传出来。她开始抓挠，伸手去抓她的手臂。所以我立刻给妻子打了电话，告诉她发生了什么。她随后开始从工作中赶回家。我坐在摇椅上，女儿在尖叫，看着我，我在想，天哪，我做了什么？我开始在脑海中模拟最坏的情况。我是否永久性地伤害了她？我们需要手术吗？天哪，孩子这么小怎么做手术啊。
So I started catastrophizing as though that were insufficient for working me up. Then I went in a different direction with the catastrophization. I started thinking, what is the doctor gonna think when I bring my daughter in? Are they gonna think I might have deliberately hurt her? And that made me feel terrible. And when you couple that with the pain I felt
所以我开始灾难化想象，仿佛这还不足以让我心烦意乱。然后我朝着另一个方向进行灾难化想象。我开始想，当我带女儿去看医生时，医生会怎么想？他们会认为我可能故意伤害了她吗？这让我感觉糟透了。当你把这些与我看着孩子因疼痛而尖叫时感受到的痛苦结合在一起时，
when just looking at my child who was screaming in pain, was a terribly chatter-provoking episode in my life. And not a particularly pleasant episode to relive. Ethan would later discover his daughter had dislocated her elbow. But in that moment, the uncertainty of not knowing what had happened allowed his chatter to spin out of control.
这真是我生命中一段极其引发杂音的插曲。而且并不是一段值得回味的愉快经历。伊森后来发现女儿的手肘脱臼了。但在那一刻，不知道发生了什么的不确定性让他的杂音失控了。
Oh, absolutely. I mean, we know that uncertainty can fuel chatter because we don't know what's gonna happen. And our mind is incredibly adept confuul chatter because we don't know what's going to happen and you know our mind is incredibly adept at simulating all sorts of possibilities and in that moment my mind was it was firing on all cylinders and that's certainly contributed to that negative state I was experiencing and I feel that this is as close to a universal experience as there is.
噢，当然。我的意思是，我们知道不确定性会助长杂音，因为我们不知道会发生什么。而我们的头脑非常擅长模拟各种可能性，在那一刻，我的大脑全速运转，这无疑加剧了我当时经历的消极状态，我觉得这几乎是一种普遍的体验。
I think almost everyone experiences this. One of the more dramatic examples of this phenomenon that took place in public involves a baseball pitcher, Rick Ankeel. And for listeners who don't know much about baseball, can you tell me a bit about Rick Ankeel and describe step by step what happened on October 3rd 2000. Sure. So Rick and Keel was a new picture in the major leagues. And when he arrived on the St. Louis Cardinals, he was touted as the next greatest thing. Not just that year, but he had the potential to be according to the pundits, one of the greatest pictures of all time. And throughout his first year in the league,
我想几乎每个人都有过这种经历。这个现象在公众视野中最戏剧性的例子之一涉及棒球投手瑞克·安基尔。对于不太了解棒球的听众，你能简单介绍一下瑞克·安基尔，并描述一下2000年10月3日发生的事情吗？当然。瑞克·安基尔是美国职业棒球大联盟的一名新秀投手。当他来到圣路易斯红雀队时，他被吹捧为下一个超级巨星。不仅是那一年，根据专家的说法，他还有潜力成为有史以来最伟大的投手之一。在他在联盟的第一年里，
that's exactly how he performed. And Keely 11 and 7 on the year in 30 starts, 194 strikeouts breaking the record, bio-ruppy. He was lights out and ace pitcher. His team ended up getting to the playoffs, and during one of the playoffs came, he took the mound. And a few up getting to the playoffs and during one of the playoff games he took the mound and a few batters into the game he did something that was very
他的表现确实如此。安基尔那年取得了11胜7负的战绩，30次先发，194次三振，打破了贝比·鲁斯的纪录。他表现得无懈可击，是一位王牌投手。他的球队最终进入了季后赛，在其中一场季后赛中，他走上了投手丘。在比赛进行了几局后，他做了一件非常
uncommon for him. The ball hit the dirt at the batter's feet and shot past the catcher. The runner-run first ambled over to second base. This was not the sort of thing fans expected from Rick and Keel. It was uncommon for him because he had such incredible control over where he placed the ball, and after he throws his wild pitch he pauses and he says to himself, huh? I just threw a wild pitch. He shrugged it off, and then he winds up to throw another pitch. And this one's even more wild than the one that came before it. Another wild pitch over the head of Hernandez, and back to the backstop. And now he's starting to wonder what is going on.
对他来说不寻常的事情。球击中了击球手脚下的泥土，从捕手身边飞过。跑垒员从一垒慢悠悠地跑到了二垒。这不是球迷们对瑞克·安基尔的期待。这对他来说很不寻常，因为他对球的落点有着惊人的控制力。在他投出那个暴投后，他停顿了一下，对自己说：“哈？我刚才投了一个暴投。”他耸了耸肩，然后准备投下一球。这一球比上一球更离谱。又是一个暴投，越过了埃尔南德斯的头顶，飞向了后挡网。现在他开始纳闷到底发生了什么。
He winds up for another pitch. Wow. The screen again hits off the backstop and right back to the backstop. And this one is even more wild than the last. It sails over the catcher and the umpire. And on and on he goes through this inning, it's incredibly painful to watch his implosion on the mound. And another wild one.
他准备投下一球。哇。球再次击中后挡网。这一球比上一球更离谱。它越过了捕手和裁判。他这一局就这样一直投下去，看着他在投手丘上的崩溃真是令人痛苦。又是一个暴投。
And Maddox will score. It's ball four to Galerogga. He finally gets that ball. A picture we previously was able to hit targets with pinpoint precision. And he's just walking batters across the bases. And ultimately has to be taken out of the game. Never regains his form when describing what he underwent on the field that day and during subsequent outings in which he tried to regain his control, he talks about this monster that was born inside him,
马多克斯得分了。这是对加莱罗加的第四个坏球。他终于拿到了那个球。一个之前能够精准命中目标的投手，现在却在把击球手一个个保送上垒。最终他不得不被换下场。他再也没能找回状态。在描述那天他在场上经历的事情，以及随后试图找回控制力的比赛时，他谈到了内心诞生的那个“怪物”，
and the monster is a name that he gives to his chatter. I wake up in the middle of the night, you know, having the nightmare that I couldn't throw a strike, I'm soaked and sweat, and it's like this thing won't even leave me alone during my sleep. Every time he would wind up to throw a pitch, he would start thinking about, is he squeezing the ball too tight or is it too loose? Is he distributing his weight appropriately? And ultimately, this monster, his chatter ended up sinking his career. his chatter ended up sinking his career.
而“怪物”就是他给自己的杂音起的名字。我会在半夜醒来，做着投不出好球的噩梦，浑身湿透，这东西甚至在我睡觉时都不放过我。每次他准备投球时，他就会开始想：我是不是把球握得太紧了，还是太松了？我的重心分配得当吗？最终，这个怪物，也就是他的杂音，彻底毁了他的职业生涯。
You see that the voice that he heard that day, this voice that he called the monster, was louder than the 52,000 fans who were in the stands watching. I mean, that's an extraordinary statement, Ethan. I think it's also a statement that rings true for many people. There's some wonderful research which shows that often what predicts how we feel at any given moment in time is not what we're actually doing, but it's the thought streaming through our head. So, you can be on a carnival ride with your kids that should be enormously fun. But you're worried
你看，那天他听到的那个声音，那个他称之为“怪物”的声音，比看台上观看比赛的52,000名球迷的声音还要大。我的意思是，这是一个非凡的陈述，伊森。我认为这也是一个对许多人来说都很真实的陈述。有一些很棒的研究表明，在任何特定时刻预测我们感受的，往往不是我们正在做的事情，而是流经我们大脑的思绪。所以，你可能正带着孩子坐嘉年华游乐设施，这本该是非常有趣的。但你却在担心
about how the last conversation went with a guest, where things were a little choppy, and you're not having fun. This speaks to, I think, exactly what, and keel experience in that moment, and what so many of us experience at times, which is when that chatter starts brewing, when that negative inner voice takes hold, that is all we can hear because it is consuming our attention. That negative inner voice is often lying in weight, ready to chime in. It refuses to let mistakes go and reminds us of them at the worst possible moment. When we come back, the many different drivers of this chatter and the psychological techniques we
上次和客人的谈话进行得如何，当时气氛有点僵，所以你玩得不开心。我认为这恰恰说明了安基尔在那一刻的经历，以及我们许多人有时会经历的事情，那就是当杂音开始酝酿，当那个消极的内心声音占据主导时，我们只能听到它，因为它消耗了我们所有的注意力。那个消极的内心声音往往潜伏着，随时准备插嘴。它拒绝让错误过去，并在最糟糕的时刻提醒我们。稍后回来，我们将探讨这种杂音的多种驱动因素，以及我们可以用来掌握内心声音的心理技巧。你正在收听《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔。
can use to master the voices inside our heads. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Psychologist Ethan Cross studies the phenomenon of self-talk and chatter. The voices we all hear incessantly inside our heads. We've seen how Chadda can take the form of a merciless tormentor. Once baseball star Rick Ankeel made one mistake, his inability to set that mistake aside produced the next mistake and the next and the next. When Ethan accidentally heard his young daughter,
这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔。心理学家伊森·克罗斯研究了自我对话和杂音的现象。那是我们所有人脑海中不断听到的声音。我们已经看到了杂音如何以无情的折磨者的形式出现。棒球明星瑞克·安基尔犯了一个错误后，他无法放下那个错误，导致了下一个错误，接着又是下一个。当伊森意外伤害了他的小女儿时，
he found it really hard to forgive himself. The harsh and unforgiving judge is a common role that is played by our inner voice. But the more Ethan studied the phenomenon of chatter, the more he realized it comes in many guises. Ethan some years ago, you made an appearance on television that set off a firestorm of chatter inside your head. Now this off a firestorm of chatter inside your head. Now, this was a different kind of chatter. Start by telling me about the TV appearance and what happened afterwards.
他发现真的很难原谅自己。严厉且不宽容的法官是我们内心声音扮演的常见角色。但伊森研究杂音现象越多，他就越意识到它有多种伪装。伊森，几年前，你参加了一次电视节目，这在你的脑海中引发了一场杂音风暴。现在，这是一种不同类型的杂音。先告诉我关于那次电视露面以及之后发生了什么。
This was early in my career and my colleagues and I published a study that we were really excited about. It dealt with the idea that when we're rejected by someone else in a romantic relationship, people may actually be referring to physical sensations in their body when they experience social pain. And this was a study we were really excited about. We didn't particularly expect it to get a lot of attention, but many people came calling and one minute I'm lecturing in introductory social psychology about the psychology of love. And the next minute I'm in a studio across campus doing an interview for the CBS evening news.
那是在我职业生涯早期，我和同事发表了一项我们非常兴奋的研究。它探讨了这样一个观点：当我们被浪漫关系中的某人拒绝时，人们在经历社会性痛苦时，可能实际上是在指代身体上的生理感觉。这是我们非常兴奋的一项研究。我们并没有特别期望它会引起太多关注，但很多人找上门来，前一分钟我还在社会心理学导论课上讲授爱情心理学，下一分钟我就在校园另一头的演播室里接受哥伦比亚广播公司晚间新闻的采访。
So when we're alone, we experience physical pain and that's a cue to say it's time to get things back on track. And that's what LeKeed is. Fast forward about a week after this interview aired, I walk into work and I notice a letter that's hand-addressed to me. And I proceeded to open the envelope. And that's where I saw a really chilling, disturbing note had been written to me. All sorts of racial slurs, threats, ugly drawings of me.
所以当我们孤独时，我们会经历身体上的痛苦，这是一种提醒，告诉我们是时候让事情回到正轨了。这就是勒基德所做的。快进到采访播出大约一周后，我走进办公室，注意到一封手写的信寄给我。我打开信封，在那里我看到了一张写给我的非常令人不寒而栗、令人不安的字条。上面写满了各种种族歧视的侮辱、威胁，还有关于我的丑陋图画。
I immediately broke out into a sweat. And the first thing I remember, the first thing I did was I showed it to my assistant just to get a second set of eyes on this to make sure I wasn't jumping to an extreme. And I looked at her face and I remember her face went white and the first thing she said to me is you need to tell someone about this. A couple of hours later after talking to folks in the department
我立刻出了一身冷汗。我记得我做的第一件事就是把它拿给我的助手看，只是为了找个人再看一眼，确保我没有反应过度。我看着她的脸，我记得她的脸变得惨白，她对我说的第一句话是：你必须把这件事告诉别人。几个小时后，在和系里的人谈过之后，
and at the university I ended up at the police station, showed them the letter, asked them what to do. So their advice to me was to keep an eye out for people who look suspicious for the next few days and make sure to drive home a different way from work each day. So that no one follows you. Which was kind of comical because at the time I lived like just a few blocks from campus. So you know, there weren't exactly many, many different ways I could go home. And this activated some chatter, some really significant chatter. For the next few days, I, few days, I couldn't sleep.
我在大学里最终去了警察局，给他们看了那封信，问他们该怎么办。他们的建议是，接下来的几天要留意看起来可疑的人，并确保每天开车回家的路线都不一样。这样就不会有人跟踪你。这有点滑稽，因为当时我住的地方离校园只有几个街区。所以，你知道，我回家的路并没有太多不同的选择。这激活了一些杂音，一些非常严重的杂音。接下来的几天，我，几天，我无法入睡。
I was pacing my house. I had my baseball bat resting on my shoulder. I was in protector mode. I was constantly thinking to myself, what have I done? Why did I do this interview? My first daughter had just been born. I've put her at risk. I put my wife at risk.
我在屋子里踱步。我把棒球棒扛在肩上。我处于保护模式。我不断地对自己想：我做了什么？我为什么要接受这个采访？我的第一个女儿刚出生。我让她处于危险之中。我让我的妻子处于危险之中。
It was really a scary moment in life and it was an all-consuming one. And when your chatter is consuming your attention for a long period of time, that makes it really hard for you to do other things in your life that matter, like your work, like advising your students, writing papers, or even being a good partner and parent to your partner and kids, right? Because they're trying to talk to me and I'm thinking about this potential threat. So that was the letter and the chatter as I refer to that episode. The chatter inside Ethan's mind brought him back to the letter over and over again. He was trying to decipher clues about the person who sent it.
那真是生命中一个可怕的时刻，而且是一个消耗一切的时刻。当你的杂音长时间消耗你的注意力时，这会让你很难做生活中其他重要的事情，比如工作、指导学生、写论文，甚至无法成为一个好的伴侣和父母，对吧？因为他们试图和我说话，而我却在想这个潜在的威胁。这就是那封信和杂音，正如我所称呼的那段插曲。伊森脑海中的杂音让他一次又一次地回到那封信上。他试图破译关于寄信人的线索。
He was trying to understand their intentions. It was actually from a nearby town which also magnified the significance of the perceived threat. But there was no reason why this person was making the accusations that they were making. There was no reason why they drew the pictures of me that they did and why they said the things they did. But that didn't make it in that moment, any less threatening. And that's what Chatter does to us because it zooms us in on the things we're concerned about, whether it be whether we belong, whether we're making grades, whether we've been rejected, or whether someone's coming to kill us.
他试图理解他们的意图。这封信实际上来自附近的一个城镇，这也放大了感知威胁的重要性。但这个人没有任何理由做出这些指控。没有任何理由画出关于我的那些图画，也没有任何理由说出他们所说的话。但在那一刻，这并没有让它变得不那么具有威胁性。这就是杂音对我们所做的，因为它让我们聚焦于我们关心的事情，无论是我们是否合群、成绩如何、是否被拒绝，还是是否有人要来杀我们。
Right? You're zoomed in so narrowly on the problem at hand, you lose the ability to see that bigger picture. So another form of chatter that's related to this this idea of the fearful prognosticator is the problem of rumination and I think many of us are affected by this, you know, we're bothered by something small and then we pull and pull and pull on that ball of thread until, small mole hills become very big mountains. A great example of this comes from the TV show Seinfeld, the character Elaine is on a crowded subway train, happily thinking about an upcoming wedding, she's about to attend.
对吧？你如此狭隘地聚焦于手头的问题，以至于失去了看到大局的能力。所以，与这种“恐惧预言家”相关的另一种杂音形式是反刍思维的问题，我认为我们许多人都受此影响，你知道，我们被一件小事困扰，然后我们就不断地拉扯那团线，直到小土丘变成了大山。这方面的一个很好的例子来自电视剧《宋飞正传》，角色伊莱恩正坐在一辆拥挤的地铁上，开心地想着她即将参加的一场婚礼。
I'm really looking forward to this. I love weddings. Maybe I'll meet somebody. Maybe not. I love weddings. Maybe I'll meet somebody. Maybe not. Oh man, we're stopping. Oh, this is great.
我真的很期待这个。我喜欢婚礼。也许我会遇到某个人。也许不会。我喜欢婚礼。也许我会遇到某个人。也许不会。噢天哪，我们停下来了。噢，这太棒了。
This is what I need. Just what I need. Okay, take it easy. I'm sure it's nothing. Probably rats on the track. They're stopping for rats. God, it's so crowded. How could there be so many people?
这正是我需要的。正是我需要的。好吧，放轻松。我相信没什么大不了的。可能是轨道上有老鼠。他们因为老鼠停下来了。天哪，太挤了。怎么会有这么多人？
What if I missed the wedding? I got the ring. What do you do? You can't get married without a ring. I can't breathe. I feel faint. Okay, take it easy. It'll start moving soon. Think about people in concentration camps, what they went through. The hostages, what would you do if you were a hostage? Think about that. This is nothing. No, it's not nothing, it's something. It's a nightmare. Help me. What's that on my leg? So obviously, even this is comedy, but I love how the writers here start with the smallest of inconveniences, and then 20 seconds later, Elaine's comparing herself being stuck on a train to being in a concentration camp. Yeah, the mind's ability to make mountains out of
如果我错过了婚礼怎么办？我有戒指。该怎么办？没有戒指怎么结婚？我喘不过气来。我感到头晕。好吧，放轻松。它很快就会动起来的。想想集中营里的人，他们经历了什么。人质，如果你是人质你会怎么做？想想那个。这没什么。不，这不是没什么，这是有事。这是一场噩梦。救救我。我腿上那是什么？所以很明显，即使这是喜剧，但我喜欢这里的编剧如何从最小的不便开始，然后20秒后，伊莱恩就把自己被困在火车上与身处集中营相提并论。是的，大脑把
mollholes and to catastrophize is truly remarkable. You know, there's this one study that I really love. It was this study done by the British anthropologist Andrew Irving. He basically went up to New Yorkers on city streets several years ago and gave them a microphone and just asked them to verbalize the stream of thoughts that were flowing through their mind at any given moment in time. And what you see in those externalized inner monologues is something very similar to what you hear Elaine going through in that clip. One thing that I think is so interesting is there's a non-linearity to our inner voice. We pinball back and forth all over the place in that clip, Elaine's not just thinking about the wedding,
小土丘变成大山并进行灾难化想象的能力确实非同寻常。你知道，我非常喜欢一项研究。那是英国人类学家安德鲁·欧文所做的一项研究。几年前，他走到纽约市的街道上，给路人一个麦克风，只是让他们把那一刻脑海中流动的思绪表达出来。你在那些外化的内心独白中看到的，与你在那个片段中听到伊莱恩所经历的非常相似。我认为非常有趣的一点是，我们的内心声音是非线性的。我们在那个片段中来回跳跃，伊莱恩不仅在想婚礼，
but she's going to the concentration camp and then she's going back to the subway conditions. We're moving back and forth very rapidly, and the other feature of these externalizing hormonologues that was so no worthy is they often dealt with negative content, not always, but that was the majority of the kinds of thoughts that were streaming through people's heads. And I just find it remarkable at how facile we are And I just find it remarkable at how fast I will we are in our ability to go from one negative thing to another and down those rabbit holes. So another hallmark of rumination is that I think we feel as if we're making progress on some problem, like we're thinking about something and we think, okay, if we think
而且她还想到了集中营，然后又回到了地铁的情况。我们非常迅速地来回移动，这些外化内心独白的另一个值得注意的特征是，它们通常涉及负面内容，虽然不总是这样，但那是流经人们脑海的大部分想法。我发现我们能够如此轻易地从一件负面事情转向另一件，并陷入那些兔子洞，这真是太了不起了。所以反刍思维的另一个标志是，我认为我们感觉自己好像在解决某个问题上取得了进展，就像我们在思考某件事，我们想，好吧，如果我们思考
about this problem, we can now make progress and solve the problem. And then, as you say, moments later, we're pinballing off 17 different things. And then we don't realize it, but we are walking in circles. We're like the people who are lost in a forest who are walking in circles. Can you talk about that? That one of the hallmarks of rumination is it has sort of the circularity to it. That we come back to the same stops over and over again, but we don't realize we're going in circles.
这个问题，我们现在就能取得进展并解决问题。然后，正如你所说，片刻之后，我们就在17件不同的事情之间来回弹跳。然后我们没有意识到，但我们是在原地打转。我们就像那些在森林里迷路的人，在原地打转。你能谈谈那个吗？反刍思维的标志之一是它有一种循环性。我们一次又一次地回到相同的站点，但我们没有意识到我们在原地打转。
You know, chatter is a term I use to refer to getting stuck in a negative thought loop, this perseverative circularity. Rumination tends to be about dwelling on the past. Worry is more about what's happening in the future, or the present, But the common theme across both of those different states is this negative circularity, this perceiverative negative cognition. And it is thought to be what psychologists call a transdiagnostic risk factor for many different forms of mental illness, ranging from various forms of depression and anxiety to other kinds
你知道，“杂音”是我用来指代陷入消极思维循环的术语，这种持续的循环性。反刍思维往往是关于沉溺于过去。担忧更多是关于未来或现在正在发生的事情，但在这两种不同状态中，共同的主题是这种消极的循环性，这种持续的消极认知。它被认为是心理学家所说的多种不同形式精神疾病的跨诊断风险因素，范围从各种形式的抑郁和焦虑到其他类型的
of negative states. For example, people who are overly aggressive and easily set off. The common theme across many of those conditions is that people are herping on some misdeed or grievance or concern over and over and over again. So we've seen how the inner voice can take the form of the harsh judge or the second guest, sir. Sometime ago, we featured Kevin Cochley on Hidden Brain, and he studies the imposter phenomenon, the phenomenon of self-doubt.
消极状态。例如，那些过于好斗且容易被激怒的人。许多这些疾病的共同主题是人们反复纠结于某种不当行为、不满或担忧。所以我们已经看到了内心声音如何以严厉的法官或“事后诸葛亮”的形式出现。前段时间，我们在《Hidden Brain》中采访了凯文·科克利，他研究了冒名顶替综合症，即自我怀疑的现象。
And in some ways, that's also connected to the story of chatter, the ways in which people who are actually very good at doing some things can sometimes start to second-guess themselves. You tell the story of Mr. Rogers on TV, he came across a serenely self-confident, but behind the scenes it was another picture altogether? Yeah, there's this wonderful Chatter artifact of sorts that the New York Times published several years ago. Fred Rogers had gone on a kind of sabbatical for a while from his show, and when he came back, he was filled with self-doubt about whether he'd be able to perform at the same level that he did prior to taking his break. And in this letter that he writes to himself, he very, very candidly expresses that vulnerability. He writes, am I kidding myself
在某种程度上，这也与杂音的故事有关，那些实际上非常擅长做某些事情的人有时会开始自我怀疑。你讲述了电视上的罗杰斯先生的故事，他表现得非常从容自信，但幕后却是另一番景象？是的，这是《纽约时报》几年前发表的一篇关于杂音的精彩文章。弗雷德·罗杰斯从他的节目中休假了一段时间，当他回来时，他对自己能否达到休假前的水平充满了自我怀疑。在这封他写给自己的信中，他非常坦诚地表达了那种脆弱。他写道：“我是在自欺欺人吗？
that I'm able to write a script again? I wonder, why don't I trust myself? After all these years, it is just as bad as ever. I wonder if every creative artist goes through the tortures of the damn trying to create. Oh well, the hour come of, and now is when I've got to do it. Get to it Fred, get to it. So this is really remarkable to me, first of. I mean we're talking about Mr. Rogers You know Mr. Rogers helped teach me how to manage my emotions growing up as he did countless other Kids and probably adults too and yet here we see him admitting to struggling with his own
我还能写出剧本吗？我纳闷，为什么我不相信自己？毕竟这么多年了，情况还是和以前一样糟糕。我想知道每个创作者在创作时是否都会经历地狱般的折磨。噢好吧，时间到了，现在是我必须做的时候了。开始吧弗雷德，开始吧。”所以这对我来说真的很了不起，首先。我的意思是我们在谈论罗杰斯先生。你知道，罗杰斯先生在我成长过程中帮助我学会了如何管理情绪，就像他帮助无数其他孩子，可能还有成年人一样，然而在这里我们看到他承认在与自己的
Self-doubt at times. So I think it's such an important message to convey to folks because it really says to people, hey, if you've ever experienced chatter, if you've ever experienced self-doubt, welcome to the human condition we all do at times. There is one final form of negative chatter worth discussing. Sometimes, the voice inside our heads takes the form not of an angry judge or a fearful warrior, but a disappointed parent or teacher. Some time ago, Hidden Brain listener Jose Velazquez
自我怀疑作斗争。所以我认为向人们传达这个信息非常重要，因为它真的告诉人们：嘿，如果你曾经经历过杂音，如果你曾经经历过自我怀疑，欢迎来到人类的境遇，我们所有人有时都会这样。还有最后一种值得讨论的消极杂音形式。有时，我们脑海中的声音不是以愤怒的法官或恐惧的预言家的形式出现，而是一个失望的父母或老师。前段时间，《Hidden Brain》的听众何塞·贝拉斯克斯
shared the story with us. I betrayed the trust of one of my closest family members and left them with a financial disaster that they had to resolve entirely on their own and it took them a better half of five years to fix it. And there doesn't pass a single day where I don't think about it and hate myself for it. And even though the person I betrayed has forgiven me has said so explicitly, I don't see how ever forgive myself. It just haunts me every single day. So, Ethan, I'm struck by the line where he says, I don't see how I can ever forgive myself.
与我们分享了他的故事。“我背叛了我最亲近的家庭成员之一的信任，给他们留下了一个他们必须完全独自解决的财务灾难，花了他们五年多的时间才修复。没有一天我不去想它，并因此痛恨自己。即使我背叛的那个人已经原谅了我，并且明确地说了出来，我还是不知道我怎么能原谅自己。它每天都在困扰着我。”所以，伊森，他说“我不知道我怎么能原谅自己”这句话让我印象深刻。
I'm wondering if you can talk for a moment about the chatter that comes in the role of shame. Chatter refers to getting stuck in those negative thought loops. The content of that negativity can vary. In some cases, it could be filled with anxiety-provoking thoughts, but in other cases, as you're referring to here, it could be filled with shame-provoking thoughts as well. Both feel awful, but in very different ways. But in my experiences, talking to people and doing research on this topic, what has become crystal clear is just how normative this experience of chatter is for people. Our inner voices can take many forms.
我想知道你能不能谈谈以羞耻感形式出现的杂音。杂音是指陷入那些消极的思维循环。这种消极情绪的内容可能会有所不同。在某些情况下，它可能充满了引发焦虑的想法，但在其他情况下，正如你在这里提到的，它也可能充满了引发羞耻感的想法。两者感觉都很糟糕，但方式截然不同。但在我与人交谈并研究这个话题的经历中，变得非常清楚的是，这种杂音的体验对人们来说是多么普遍。我们的内心声音可以采取多种形式。
They can cause us enormous anguish. They can cause friction in our relationships. They can impair our performance, destabilize us. It's enough to make anyone wish for a little peace and quiet. That's exactly what happened to the neuroscientist, Jill Bolteiler. In 1996, she suffered a stroke that silenced the voice of her inner tormentor. She described what that change was like in a TED Talk. My brain chatter went totally silent. Just like someone took a remote control and pushed the mute button, total silence.
它们会给我们带来巨大的痛苦。它们会在我们的关系中造成摩擦。它们会损害我们的表现，使我们不稳定。这足以让任何人希望获得一点平静。这正是神经科学家吉尔·博尔特·泰勒所经历的。1996年，她中风了，这让她的内心折磨者的声音沉默了。她在TED演讲中描述了那种变化。“我的大脑杂音完全沉默了。就像有人拿了一个遥控器按下了静音键，完全的寂静。”
And at first I was shocked to find myself inside of a silent mind. And I affectionately refer to this space as La La Land. But it was beautiful there. Imagine what it would be like to lose 37 years of emotional baggage. Oh, I felt euphoria. When we come back, Jill Bull Taylor discovered something.
“起初，我惊讶地发现自己处于一个安静的头脑中。我亲切地称这个空间为‘啦啦之地’。但那里很美。想象一下，丢掉37年的情感包袱会是什么感觉。噢，我感到了欣快。”当我们回来时，吉尔·博尔特·泰勒发现了一件事。
That nagging, bothersome voice she was so happy to lose, she starts to miss it. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Psychologist Ethan Cross is the author of the book, Chatter. He has studied the different roles of the voices we hear inside our heads, the harsh judge, the fearful prognosticator, the repetitive ruminator. One of the puzzles that arises from this area of research is this. If our inner voice is consistently a source of anxiety or a driver of depression, why do we have an inner voice
那个她很高兴失去的唠叨、烦人的声音，她开始想念它了。你正在收听《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔。这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔。心理学家伊森·克罗斯是《杂音》一书的作者。他研究了我们脑海中听到的声音的不同角色：严厉的法官、恐惧的预言家、重复的反刍者。这项研究中出现的一个谜题是：如果我们的内心声音始终是焦虑的来源或抑郁的驱动力，为什么我们会有内心声音
at all? Shouldn't natural selection have found a way over thousands of years to remove something that causes so much harm? Ethan, you've called introspection the great puzzle of the human mind. What is paradoxical about it? Well, what's paradoxical about it is that on the one hand, the ability to introspect is a remarkable tool that is a source of innovation. It's a tool that lets us solve problems. If you think about verbal introspection specifically, what many people describe as
呢？自然选择难道不应该在几千年的时间里找到一种方法来消除这种造成如此多伤害的东西吗？伊森，你称内省为人类思维的伟大谜题。它有什么矛盾之处？嗯，矛盾之处在于，一方面，内省的能力是一种非凡的工具，是创新的源泉。它是一种让我们解决问题的工具。如果你具体思考语言内省，许多人将其描述为
the inner voice, what that refers to specifically as our ability to silently use language to reflect on our lives. And that lets us do many, many different things. Number one, your inner voice lets you keep information active in your head for very short periods of time. It's part of what we call our verbal working memory system. So if you go to the grocery store, and like me, five minutes after you get there,
内心声音，它具体指的是我们默默使用语言来反思我们生活的能力。这让我们能做许多许多不同的事情。第一，你的内心声音让你能在很短的时间内保持信息在脑海中活跃。它是我们所谓的言语工作记忆系统的一部分。所以如果你去杂货店，像我一样，到了那里五分钟后，
you forget what you were supposed to buy, and you pause, and you think to yourself, why was I supposed to get? Geez, yogurt, oranges. That's you're using your inner voice. You're using it to retain information. But we also use that inner voice to do other things like simulate and plan. Before giving a new presentation, I will go for a walk around my neighborhood and I'll go through what I'm going to say,
你忘了你应该买什么，你停下来，对自己想：我应该买什么？天哪，酸奶，橙子。那就是你在使用你的内心声音。你在用它来保留信息。但我们也使用那个内心声音来做其他事情，比如模拟和计划。在进行新的演讲之前，我会在我的社区周围散步，我会过一遍我要说的话，
often word for word, in my mind. We also use our inner voice to control ourselves. This morning I was exercising, it was a hard workout, I was literally coaching myself along. Come on, you got this, seven more reps, then you get a break, and then I count to down, seven, six, five. So we can use that inner voice to be a coach. And then finally, we use our inner voice to tell stories, to create narratives that help us understand our experiences in this wacky world, and those narratives that we create, they give shape to our sense of who we are. I think of the inner voice and more broadly
通常是在脑海中逐字逐句地过。我们也使用我们的内心声音来控制自己。今天早上我在锻炼，那是一次艰苦的训练，我真的在指导自己。加油，你可以的，再做七次，然后你就可以休息了，然后我倒数，七，六，五。所以我们可以使用那个内心声音作为教练。最后，我们使用我们的内心声音来讲述故事，创造叙事来帮助我们理解在这个古怪世界中的经历，而我们创造的那些叙事，它们塑造了我们对自我的认知。我认为内心声音更广泛地
in respect, as a kind of Swiss army knife of the human mind that lets us do many, many different things. I'm thinking about one other feature that the inner voice gives us, Ethan, when we do something that's wrong, we often castigate ourselves, we are mad at ourselves, we second-guess ourselves, we experience shame, we experience remorse, and obviously it's not fun to go through those things, but of course, if we imagine a world where we didn't go through them, where we did something wrong, where we didn't reflect back on what happened, we might be entirely prone to make the same mistakes over and over again.
内省，是人类思维的一种瑞士军刀，让我们能做许多许多不同的事情。我正在思考内心声音给我们的另一个特征，伊森，当我们做错事时，我们经常责备自己，我们对自己生气，我们事后怀疑自己，我们经历羞耻，我们经历悔恨，显然经历这些事情并不好玩，但当然，如果我们想象一个我们没有经历这些的世界，当我们做错事时，当我们没有反思发生的事情时，我们可能完全容易一次又一次地犯同样的错误。
Experiencing negativity and negative emotions isn't something that we want to shy away from. Many scientists, myself included, believe that negative emotions are functional when experienced in the right dosage. We evolve the capacity to experience shame, regret, anger, sadness. You fill in your favorite negative emotion for a reason. They prepare us for dealing with that situation that we're managing, and they often serve as cues to say, hey, you need to focus here so you don't repeat this mistake again. So we don't want to rid ourselves of negativity. What we do want to figure out is how to prevent those small spikes
经历消极情绪和负面情绪并不是我们想要回避的事情。许多科学家，包括我自己，认为负面情绪在剂量合适时是有功能的。我们进化出了体验羞耻、遗憾、愤怒、悲伤的能力。你可以填入你最喜欢的负面情绪，这是有原因的。它们让我们为处理我们正在管理的那个情况做好准备，而且它们往往作为提醒，说：嘿，你需要在这里集中注意力，这样你就不会再犯这个错误了。所以我们不想摆脱消极情绪。我们想要弄清楚的是如何防止那些小的
of negative emotions from morphing into chatter. So earlier in the episode, we explored the story of the neuroscientist Jill Boltaylor. She suffered a stroke that left her unable to engage in introspection. And at first she welcomed the absence of her bothersome in her voice. But Ethan finished the story for me. Did the relief that Jill Boltaylor felt at losing her inner voice was that long-lasting? What ended up happening was the euphoria that she initially felt when all of her chatter went away, that morphed into a state of dysfunction as time went on. Because although she stopped worrying and ruminating, she also stopped being able to do
负面情绪尖峰演变成杂音。所以早些时候，我们探讨了神经科学家吉尔·博尔特·泰勒的故事。她中风了，导致她无法进行内省。起初，她欢迎那种烦人的内心声音的消失。但伊森，帮我讲完这个故事。吉尔·博尔特·泰勒因失去内心声音而感到的解脱是持久的吗？最终发生的事情是，当她所有的杂音消失时，她最初感到的欣快感，随着时间的推移演变成了一种功能障碍状态。因为虽然她停止了担忧和反刍，但她也停止了能够做
basic things like keep information active in our head. The inner voice is part of your working memory system. She lost that ability to organize her thinking, to make sense of what was happening in her world. And the lesson that she learned from going through this stroke was that the goal for her was no longer to identify ways of silencing her inner voice, of getting rid of it.
比如保持信息在我们头脑中活跃等基本功能。内心独白是你工作记忆系统的一部分。她失去了组织思维、理解周围世界正在发生什么的能力。她在中风后学到的教训是，她的目标不再是寻找压制内心独白或摆脱它的方法。
Instead, the goal became to learn how to manage that inner voice more effectively. So, I want to take you back to a story that you told me at the start of this episode. And I want to have you tell me how you in some ways managed to control the chatter that was unfolding inside your head. This was after you went on TV and you received a threatening letter, you were terrified, you started pacing about your house at night with a baseball bat patrolling your house. At one point, Ethan, you sat down at your computer and began to search for ways that you could protect yourself. What were you hoping to find with your Google search and what happened subsequently?
相反，目标变成了学习如何更有效地管理这种内心独白。所以，我想带你回到你在本集开头告诉我的那个故事。我想让你告诉我，你是如何在某种程度上设法控制脑海中不断涌现的杂念的。那是在你上电视并收到一封威胁信之后，你当时非常害怕，晚上开始拿着棒球棍在家里巡逻。有一次，伊森，你坐在电脑前，开始搜索保护自己的方法。你当时希望通过谷歌搜索找到什么？后来又发生了什么？
Look, anyone who's experienced chatter knows that the rabbit hole, when you're really in it, can take you down it quite deep and I was very deep down the rabbit hole. And at the very worst of it, I sat down at my laptop and I had the thought, why don't I search for a bodyguard that specializes in protecting academics? And I didn't actually hit enter on the search. I did type it, but then I thought to myself, first, what if someone sees you type this? They'll think you've lost it. And then I actually said to myself, what are you doing? Get your act together. And I started talking to myself like I was talking to someone else. And it instantly snapped me out of that very narrow view of my situation that was filled with
听着，任何经历过杂念的人都知道，当你真正陷入其中时，那个“兔子洞”会让你陷得很深，而我当时就陷得非常深。在最糟糕的时候，我坐在笔记本电脑前，心想，为什么我不搜索一下专门保护学者的保镖呢？我其实并没有按下搜索键。我确实输入了，但随后我对自己说，首先，如果有人看到你输入这个怎么办？他们会觉得你疯了。然后我真的对自己说，你在干什么？振作起来。我开始对自己说话，就像在和别人说话一样。这瞬间让我从那种狭隘的、充满
thoughts about threat and oh my God, what if this happens? And it was more, it was a broader view that I adopted well look I'm not the first person to experience this situation the police told me that other folks get letters on occasion They usually blow over this will too. It's not doing any good to not sleep so why don't you go upstairs and stop this stuff and upstairs and stop this stuff. And that's exactly what I did. And interestingly enough, if you think back to that letter by Fred Rogers that I read before,
对威胁的担忧以及“天哪，如果发生这种情况怎么办”的想法中解脱出来。我采取了一种更广阔的视角，好吧，我不是第一个经历这种情况的人，警察告诉我，其他人偶尔也会收到信件，通常都会过去，这次也会。不睡觉没有任何好处，所以你为什么不上楼去，停止这些胡思乱想。于是我上楼停止了这些念头。而有趣的是，如果你回想一下我之前读的那封弗雷德·罗杰斯的信，
he did something very similar. He used his own name. It was almost as though in both of our circumstances, we were thrust into this other advisory mode. It was like we were giving advice to a good friend. And we then went on to do research on this tool. We call it Distanced Self-Talk. And what it involves doing is trying to coach yourself through your chatter using your own name or the second person pronoun you. And it turns out this
他做了非常相似的事情。他用了他自己的名字。在我们的两种情况下，我们似乎都被推入了这种建议模式。就像我们在给一位好朋友提建议一样。后来我们对这个工具进行了研究。我们称之为“远距离自我对话”。它涉及的内容是尝试使用你自己的名字或第二人称代词“你”来引导自己克服杂念。事实证明，这
is a useful tool for helping people gain distance from what they're going through in ways that can be quite useful. So I want you to talk a little bit about that research because in some ways, beyond the fact that talking to yourself, as if you were outside yourself helped you, you actually have data to show that, in fact, this technique is effective. You publish a study where you asked volunteers
是一个有用的工具，可以帮助人们以非常有益的方式与他们正在经历的事情保持距离。所以我想请你谈谈那项研究，因为在某种程度上，除了像对待别人一样对自己说话对你有帮助之外，你实际上有数据表明，这种技巧确实有效。你发表了一项研究，要求志愿者
to think about personal events that they will worry about and you asked volunteers to think about personal events that they were worried about, and then ask them to think about those events either in the first person or using a different pronoun. Tell me how you ran that study and how it unfolded. Well, what we did in that study is we had people first tell us about experiences from their past that people might ruminate about and in another study it dealt with future worries and concerns. And then during the study we would have people reflect on those experiences. We'd have them think about them and then try to really work through their deepest thoughts and feelings surrounding
思考他们担心的个人事件，然后要求他们以第一人称或使用不同的代词来思考这些事件。告诉我你是如何进行这项研究的，以及它是如何展开的。嗯，我们在那项研究中所做的是，首先让人们告诉我们他们过去可能反复思考的经历，在另一项研究中，它涉及未来的担忧和顾虑。然后在研究过程中，我们会让人们反思这些经历。我们会让他们思考这些经历，然后尝试真正理清围绕
those events. Half of the time we had them try to work through their feelings as we normally do in the first person. So, why did I feel this way? What was going on? In the other half of the time, though, we'd have them use their own name and the second person pronoun you. So, Ethan, why did you feel this way? What was going on? And what we found was across both studies, people consistently felt less upset when they use what we call distance self-talk, when they use their name, and the second person pronoun you
这些事件的最深层的想法和感受。有一半的时间，我们让他们尝试像往常一样以第一人称来处理自己的感受。比如，为什么我会有这种感觉？发生了什么事？而在另外一半时间里，我们让他们使用自己的名字和第二人称代词“你”。比如，伊森，你为什么会有这种感觉？发生了什么事？我们发现，在两项研究中，当人们使用我们所说的“远距离自我对话”，即使用他们的名字和第二人称代词“你”时，
to try to work through and make sense of what they were going through. What this helps us do is it helps us step back and think about our circumstances more similar to how we would think about something that's happening to another person. And when we do that, we have the enhanced ability to be more objective and deliberate when we think about our problems. So besides using our names or second-person pronouns when talking to ourselves. It turns out there are also other ways of creating psychological distance from our problems.
他们感到不那么难过了。这有助于我们退后一步，以类似于我们看待发生在别人身上的事情的方式来思考我们的处境。当我们这样做时，我们在思考问题时就有了更客观、更审慎的增强能力。所以，除了在对自己说话时使用我们的名字或第二人称代词外，事实证明还有其他方法可以与我们的问题产生心理距离。
And you found many of these techniques to be beneficial. One of these techniques involves visualization, changing the way we see things in our mind's eye. Can you tell me about the work that you and your colleagues have done to test the idea of adopting what's called a fly on the wall perspective on our own problems? Yeah, so when we think about negative experiences or when we anticipate future ones as well, we often have mental imagery surrounding it. And research has shown that we can think about different experiences in our lives from
你发现其中许多技巧都是有益的。其中一种技巧涉及可视化，改变我们在脑海中看待事物的方式。你能告诉我你和你的同事为测试采用所谓的“墙上苍蝇”视角来看待我们自己的问题所做的工作吗？是的，所以当我们思考负面经历或预见未来的经历时，我们经常会产生围绕它的心理意象。研究表明，我们可以从
different perspectives. So you can conjure up a mental snapshot of a past event and actually replay it happening in your own mind from a first person perspective. Or you can also think about that same experience, but from a third person perspective, like a fly on the wall peering down on the scene. Research has shown that when people adopt a third person or a fly in the wall perspective, that tends to be linked with lower levels of emotionality, and that's true for both positive and negative experiences. In one set of studies, we found that when participants were provoked, when an experimenter in the lab acted in a very rude and insulting way to them.
不同的视角思考我们生活中的不同经历。你可以唤起过去事件的心理快照，并实际上以第一人称视角在自己的脑海中重播它。或者你也可以从第三人称视角思考同样的经历，就像一只墙上的苍蝇俯视着现场。研究表明，当人们采用第三人称或“墙上苍蝇”视角时，这往往与较低的情绪水平相关，这对于积极和消极的经历都是如此。在一组研究中，我们发现当参与者受到挑衅时，即实验室里的实验者以非常粗鲁和侮辱性的方式对待他们时。
If we ask people to reflect on the provocation from a distance, they were much less likely to be aggressive towards that experimenter when given the opportunity than people who were directed to just reflect on the experience as they normally would in the first person. And so more broadly, what I think this speaks to is the fact that, look, it's very easy for us to become consumed with negativity. And when we're consumed with that negativity, we often say things and do things that we would never dream of doing if the emotional amplitude was just a little bit lower. And that's what we see happening
如果我们要求人们从远处反思这种挑衅，当有机会时，他们表现出对实验者的攻击性的可能性要比那些被指示像往常一样以第一人称反思经历的人低得多。因此，更广泛地说，我认为这说明了一个事实，即我们很容易被消极情绪所吞噬。当我们被那种消极情绪吞噬时，我们经常会说出和做出一些事情，如果情绪幅度稍微低一点，我们做梦也不会那样做。这就是我们看到的
with many of these different kinds of distancing techniques. It turns down the temperature just a little bit. It doesn't, I should, and I think this is an important point to convey. When people distance in our studies, we don't take a negative experience and turn it into a joyfully blissfully positive event. When I coached myself, you know, Ethan, what are you doing bodyguards for academics?
许多这些不同类型的疏离技巧所发生的情况。它稍微降低了温度。我不认为，我认为这是一个需要传达的重要观点。当人们在我们的研究中进行疏离时，我们并没有把负面经历变成一件快乐、幸福的积极事件。当我引导自己时，你知道，“伊森，你为什么要给学者找保镖？”
It was still a negative situation I was dealing with. But the intensity of it was diminished to a point where I could think about it more objectively and deliberately. And that can be really useful. And often the difference between being mired in chatter on the one hand and working through a negative experience adaptively on the other. So we've seen how creating a little distance using language can be effective and creating a little distance using spatial imagination can be effective. It turns out there's a third way we can also achieve some distance from our own problems.
我处理的仍然是一个负面的情况。但它的强度降低到了我可以更客观、更审慎地思考它的程度。这真的很有用。这通常是一方面陷入杂念，另一方面适应性地处理负面经历之间的区别。所以我们已经看到了使用语言创造一点距离是如何有效的，以及使用空间想象力创造一点距离也是有效的。事实证明，我们还可以通过第三种方式与我们自己的问题保持距离。
Can you talk about the idea of temporal distance, Ethan? Yeah, I love this distancing tactic. It's one that Oslem Ayduk and one of her colleagues discovered a few years ago. What it involves doing is remarkably simple and effective. So take your latest worry, rather than think about how awful the circumstance is right now, think about how you're going to feel sometime down the road in the future. What that does, what engaging in that form of what
你能谈谈时间距离的概念吗，伊森？是的，我喜欢这种疏离策略。这是奥斯莱姆·艾杜克和她的一位同事几年前发现的。它涉及的内容非常简单有效。所以，拿你最近的担忧来说，与其思考现在的情况有多糟糕，不如想想你在未来的某个时候会有什么感觉。这样做，参与这种形式的
we often call mental time travel does for us, is it makes it clear that whatever we're dealing with, as awful as it is, it will eventually pass. And that gives us hope that can be a very powerful antidote to a negative mind that is overwhelmed with chatter. Ethan and other researchers have also found it helps to give new labels to our emotions. When a negative voice inside you warns of all the bad things that could happen and you feel yourself getting anxious, relabel that anxiety. Another tool that can help people involves changing the way we interpret what we're going through shifting from thinking about our circumstances as a threat to thinking about it as a challenge.
我们通常称之为“心理时间旅行”的事情，会让我们清楚地认识到，无论我们正在处理什么，尽管它很糟糕，但它最终都会过去。这给了我们希望，这可以成为对抗被杂念淹没的消极头脑的强力解药。伊森和其他研究人员还发现，给我们的情绪贴上新的标签也有帮助。当内心的负面声音警告所有可能发生的坏事，而你感到自己变得焦虑时，重新标记那种焦虑。另一个可以帮助人们的工具涉及改变我们解释正在经历的事情的方式，从把我们的处境视为威胁转变为视为挑战。
And the way this works is as follows. When people are experiencing stress, they often ask themselves, and this often happens subconsciously to kinds of questions. What's required of me in this situation and what resources do I possess to manage it? If you answer those questions, if you know, okay, there's a lot that's being asked of me, and no way I can deal with this, that elicits a threat appraisal which predicts all sorts of bad stuff, poor performance, poor subjective feelings, poor health. But as we saw in a recent conversation with mindset's researcher Alia Kram, we can see
其工作方式如下。当人们经历压力时，他们经常会下意识地问自己两个问题：在这种情况下我需要做什么？我拥有什么资源来管理它？如果你回答了这些问题，如果你知道，好吧，有很多要求我的地方，我无法处理，这会引发威胁评估，从而预示着各种坏事，表现不佳，主观感受差，健康状况差。但正如我们在最近与思维模式研究员阿莉亚·克拉姆的对话中所看到的，我们可以看到
better outcomes when we relabel problems, not as threats, but as challenges. That predicts the opposite set of outcomes, better performance, better subjective experience, better physiological responses. And so that's another switch, another lever you can pull to shift how you're functioning in a particular situation. Go from threat to challenge. We've looked at several techniques that individuals can practice, but it's striking, of course, that long before you had psychological signs come up with solutions to the problem of chatter, societies have been grappling with ways to help people deal with stressors and out of control anxiety. You've cited a remarkable study
当我们把问题重新标记为挑战而不是威胁时，会有更好的结果。这预示着相反的结果，更好的表现，更好的主观体验，更好的生理反应。所以这是另一个开关，另一个你可以拉动的杠杆，来改变你在特定情况下的运作方式。从威胁转向挑战。我们已经研究了个人可以练习的几种技巧，但令人惊讶的是，当然，早在心理学出现解决杂念问题的方案之前，社会就已经在努力寻找帮助人们应对压力源和失控焦虑的方法。你引用了一项了不起的研究，
looking at a technique practiced by Israeli women living in war zones. What did the women do to bring their anxieties and that chatter under control? Well, they activated an ancient Chatterfiting tool, which was they prayed ritualistically and praying for them was associated with reductions in anxiety. You look at cultures around the world, think about the death of a loved one. Lots of different religions prescribe very, very different kinds of rituals for engaging with that kind of chatter, provoking event. And research shows that engaging in a ritual can actually be helpful for modulating our
观察以色列生活在战区的妇女所采用的一种技巧。这些妇女做了什么来控制她们的焦虑和杂念？嗯，她们激活了一种古老的“抗杂念”工具，那就是她们进行仪式性的祈祷，对她们来说，祈祷与焦虑的减轻有关。看看世界各地的文化，想想亲人的去世。许多不同的宗教为应对那种引发杂念的事件规定了非常、非常不同的仪式。研究表明，参与仪式实际上有助于调节我们的
chatter. One thing to keep in mind is when we're experiencing chatter, we often feel like we don't have control over the thoughts and feelings that are streaming through our head. And one of the reasons we think rituals are helpful is because a ritual is under your control. It's a rigid sequence of behaviors that you perform the same way every time. That's something that you have agency over. And that's a way of compensating for the lack of control we often feel when we're struggling with chatter. Another way that they can aid us is
杂念。要记住的一件事是，当我们经历杂念时，我们经常觉得我们无法控制脑海中流动的想法和感受。我们认为仪式有帮助的原因之一是因为仪式在你的控制之下。这是一系列严格的行为序列，你每次都以同样的方式执行。这是你可以掌控的事情。这是一种补偿我们在与杂念斗争时经常感到的缺乏控制感的方法。它们可以帮助我们的另一种方式是
they're often intentionally demanding, which is to say rituals are often complicated and to execute them, we have to focus on the individual parts of performing those rituals. And that can take our attention away momentarily from the chatter we're experiencing and give us a bit of of distraction and so that's another pathway through which rituals can help. And of course we see these rituals not just in the context of religion we see this in sports all the time. You tell the story of the Australian swimmer Stephanie Rice before every race she swings her arms eight times, presses her goggles four times, touches her cap four times.
它们通常是有意要求的，也就是说，仪式通常很复杂，为了执行它们，我们必须专注于执行这些仪式的各个部分。这可以暂时把我们的注意力从我们正在经历的杂念中转移开，给我们一点分心，所以这是仪式可以提供帮助的另一个途径。当然，我们不仅在宗教背景下看到这些仪式，我们在体育运动中也经常看到。你讲了澳大利亚游泳运动员斯蒂芬妮·赖斯的故事，在每场比赛前，她挥动手臂八次，按护目镜四次，摸泳帽四次。
I mean, it does sound religious, but clearly it's just about sports performance. Yeah, so there's research which has shown that you can give people arbitrary rituals to engage in, you know, clap their hands three times, spin around in their seat twice, and then tap their head. And engaging in those kinds of non-religious rituals can be beneficial as well. Probably the most famous athlete who's known for doing rituals is Rafael Nadal. Several years ago, a journalist asked Nadal, what's the hardest thing you struggle with on the tennis court? And his answer surprised a lot of people because he didn't say the hardest thing I do is, you know, making sure I keep my serve in check or return my opponent's backhand.
我的意思是，这听起来确实很宗教，但显然这只是关于运动表现。是的，有研究表明，你可以给人们任意的仪式来参与，你知道，拍手三次，在座位上转两圈，然后拍拍头。参与这些非宗教仪式也可能是有益的。可能最著名的以做仪式而闻名的运动员是拉斐尔·纳达尔。几年前，一位记者问纳达尔，你在网球场上最难克服的事情是什么？他的回答让很多人感到惊讶，因为他没有说我做的最难的事情是，你知道，确保我的发球保持在控制范围内或回击对手的反手。
And said he says, the hardest thing I struggle with is to battle the voice inside my head. The hardest thing he struggles with is his chatter on the court. And if you watch Nadal play, you will see his solution for managing that chatter. He engages in elaborate rituals from the time he enters the court to before every single serve, he has specific rituals that he engages in. And when he's been asked, why do you do these wacky rituals? He says, and I quote, these rituals are a way of ordering my mind, providing the order I seek in a match. And again, Raphael the Down finds a way. I understand that you have some rituals of your own to combat your inner chatter before
相反，他说，我最难克服的是与脑海中的声音作斗争。他最难克服的是他在球场上的杂念。如果你看纳达尔打球，你会看到他管理这种杂念的解决方案。他从进入球场到每次发球前都进行精心设计的仪式，他有特定的仪式。当被问及，你为什么要进行这些古怪的仪式时？他说，我引用一下，这些仪式是一种整理我头脑的方式，提供我在比赛中寻求的秩序。再一次，拉斐尔·纳达尔找到了方法。我听说你在发表重要演讲之前也有自己的一些仪式来对抗内心的杂念。
giving a big speech. I do. I will pound a fist into my hand two or three times. I will give myself a little mini, very brief, distant self-talk, PAPTOK. You know, come on, man, you've got this. And if it's a really, really high stakes event, I've been known to do a few pushups right before Showtime as well.
是的。我会用拳头捶手两三次。我会给自己做一个简短的、非常简短的“远距离自我对话”式的加油。你知道，“来吧，伙计，你能行的。”如果这是一个非常、非常高风险的事件，我也曾在上台前做过几个俯卧撑。
Ha-ha-ha. We started this conversation by having you tell me about your experience as a young undergrad at Penn who was dealing with setbacks when you first got a college. One of the people you reached out to for help at that time was your dad and it turns out that your dad played a really formative role not just in helping you while you were at Penn, but in some ways helping you think about the whole idea of introspection more generally. I'm wondering if you could tell me a little bit
哈哈。我们开始这次谈话时，你告诉我你作为宾夕法尼亚大学的一名年轻本科生，在刚上大学时处理挫折的经历。当时你寻求帮助的人之一是你的父亲，事实证明，你的父亲不仅在你宾大期间帮助了你，而且在某种程度上，他在帮助你思考整个内省的概念方面发挥了非常重要的作用。我想知道你是否能告诉我一点
about your dad and the connection between his insights and the work that you've been doing these last several decades. One of the interesting ahas I had was that, although I had been researching chatter and how to manage it for about 20 years, I've been thinking about it for close to 40. The reason for that is I had an unconventional dad.
关于你父亲以及他的见解与你过去几十年来所做的工作之间的联系。我有一个有趣的顿悟，虽然我研究杂念以及如何管理它已经大约20年了，但我思考它已经接近40年了。原因是我有一个非传统的父亲。
My dad was someone who, on the one hand, love watching the New York Yankees and driving aggressively on the streets of Brooklyn and, you know, it's chain smoking, you know, Brooklyn bushy mustache kind of guy, but when he wasn't doing all those things, he was, he was reading Eastern philosophy and the Bhagavad Gita and meditating. And when he wasn't doing those things, he was talking to me as a three-year-old about what he was learning about. He wasn't a college grad or, you know, this wasn't, he wasn't a professor, by the way. It's just a hobby that he had.
我父亲是一个一方面喜欢看纽约洋基队比赛，在布鲁克林的街道上激进驾驶，你知道，是一个连锁吸烟、留着布鲁克林浓密胡子的人，但当他不做所有这些事情时，他就在阅读东方哲学和《薄伽梵歌》并进行冥想。当他不忙于这些事情时，他会作为一个三岁的孩子和我谈论他正在学习的东西。顺便说一句，他不是大学毕业生，也不是教授。这只是他的一个爱好。
He was fascinated by the mind and our ability to manage it. And the message that he conveyed to me from the time I was a little kid was, whenever something is going wrong, turn your attention and work and try to work through the situation. The way he said that to me was, you know, he'd give me this corny phrase, go inside, find the kernel of truth, you would say.
他着迷于头脑以及我们管理它的能力。他从我小时候起就传达给我的信息是，每当事情出错时，就把你的注意力转向内心，尝试理清情况。他对我说的表达方式是，你知道，他会给我这个老套的短语，“走进内心，找到真理的核心”，他会这样说。
That was a message that he just conveyed to me over and over. I mean, I was a little kid and it was a tool that I, as a result, relied on throughout my child and adolescent. So, I get into an argument or I ask a girl out, they'd say no, I'd go inside to the introspect, try to work through, figure out why this happened, come up with a solution and move on. And then I got to pen, I experienced some of my own chatter,
那是他一遍又一遍传达给我的信息。我的意思是，我当时还是个小孩子，结果我在整个童年和青春期都依赖这个工具。所以，我和人争吵，或者我约女孩出去，她们拒绝了，我会走进内心进行内省，尝试理清思路，弄清楚为什么会发生这种情况，想出一个解决方案，然后继续前进。然后我到了宾大，经历了一些我自己的杂念，
and then I ended up taking a psychology class and I learned in that class that lots of people do exactly what my dad had told me to do when they struggle with something and they benefit as a result. This ability to introspect was a remarkable tool. But in some cases, that tool failed lots of people as well and discovering that puzzle, why is it that we have this tool? Sometimes it helps, other times it hurts us.
最后我上了一门心理学课，我在那门课上了解到，很多人在遇到困难时，做的正是我的父亲告诉我的事情，并且因此受益。这种内省的能力是一个了不起的工具。但在某些情况下，这个工具也让很多人失败了，发现那个谜题，为什么我们有这个工具？有时它有帮助，有时它会伤害我们。
That became a passion of mine that I've been trying to solve ever since. Ethan Cross is a psychologist at the University of Michigan. He's the author of the book, Chatter, the voice in our head, why it matters, and how to harness it. Ethan, thank you for talking to me today on Hidden Brain. Thanks so much for having me, Shankar, it was a pleasure. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Correll, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor.
这成了我一直试图解决的激情所在。伊森·克罗斯是密歇根大学的心理学家。他是《杂念：我们脑海中的声音，为什么它很重要，以及如何驾驭它》一书的作者。伊森，感谢你今天在《隐藏的大脑》节目中与我交谈。非常感谢你的邀请，尚卡尔，很高兴能来。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲·保罗、克里斯汀·黄、劳拉·科雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。
Our unsung hero this week is Marty Bonneffat. Marty is a small business benefits consultant with Howard W. Phillips in company. He's in Washington, DC. He was really helpful when we recently had to explore health insurance options for our company Marty was responsive friendly and knew how to clearly explain jargony topics to non-exports. We really appreciate your help Marty Next week we continue our YouTube.io series with a look at how we make decisions We usually think that we know what's best for ourselves, but very often that is not true.
我们本周的无名英雄是马蒂·邦内法特。马蒂是华盛顿特区霍华德·W·菲利普斯公司的一名小型企业福利顾问。当我们最近不得不为公司探索健康保险选择时，他真的很有帮助。马蒂反应迅速、友好，并且知道如何向非专家清晰地解释行话。我们非常感谢你的帮助，马蒂。下周，我们将继续我们的YouTube.io系列节目，看看我们是如何做决定的。我们通常认为我们知道什么对自己最好，但很多时候事实并非如此。
You know, it's just fascinating how easily people can convince themselves that they know what they're doing, even when we know they don't. Next week, we'll explore a better way. If you're a fan of the show, if you feel we have given you ideas that have been useful in your life, please help us make more episodes like this. Go to support.hiddenbrain.org. Again, that's support.hiddenbrain.org and show us you have our back.
你知道，人们如此容易说服自己他们知道自己在做什么，即使我们知道他们不知道，这真是太迷人了。下周，我们将探索一种更好的方法。如果你是这个节目的粉丝，如果你觉得我们为你提供了在你生活中很有用的想法，请帮助我们制作更多这样的剧集。请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。再说一遍，是 support.hiddenbrain.org，向我们展示你支持我们。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。